hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round four of the
united states chess championship
yesterday was a rest day so we have time
to check up on a few more games and this
one is uh very very interesting because
it features not only a really enjoyable
end game but also the london system and
i know how much everyone has a problem
facing the london system so here we can
see uh how uh well just one uh one of
the approaches that one could take in
handling the london system so without
further ado let's check it out sam
shanklin versus lanier dominguez perez
uh sam with the white pieces opens with
d4 uh we have d5 by perez knight to f3
knight to f6 and now bishop to f4 going
for the london system we have e6 e3 and
now uh striking in the center with c5 so
here we have c3 defending the center and
the bishop to d6 now going after this
bishop and this is a very standard line
if you don't uh you know try anything
crazy and the one that should arise
fairly often and the most commonly
played idea here is just retreating the
bishop to g3 because if black captures
you do not mind opening up the h file
for your rook also knight to e5 is a a
well-known idea but here we have bishop
to b5 check this is how shankland wants
to deal with this knight to c6 and the
immediate captures with check so b
captures on c6 bishop captures on d6
queen captures and now queen to a4 so
two early traits and now uh a nice
developing move by the queen putting
pressure on this c6 pawn so here black
just castles and now uh this is uh
actually a well-known position it was um
uh reached this year in new in chess
classic between lebon ariana and wesley
so levon played queen to a3 uh sort of
pinning this pawn because the queen on
d6 is undefended and lavon was able to
win this game against wesley so but here
we have knight beat to d2 and it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game so let's see how uh black deals
with this we have c captures on d4 as
the queen a3 was not played we should
get rid of this double pawn right away c
captures and denounce c5 getting rid rid
of our weak c6 pawn as well we have
castles by white and now uh you could
advance the pawn all the way to c4 but
that's uh considered sort of
anti-positional uh even though nowadays
uh you know with super strong modern
engines anti-positional moves are being
played all the time but
maybe it's a bit unpleasant you could
later undermine the pawn with some like
ee4 or b3 of course the rooks will come
to the c file and maybe it's going to be
a little weak for black but of course it
can be played but here we have queen to
a6 uh offering a queen trade white's
queen is a bit more active so we really
want to trade our uh queens and get our
bishop into the game and also uh black
uh white has two knights and we have a
bishop and the knight so we we are
interested in getting rid of the queens
and even the rooks because we have uh
sort of a bishop against a knight
advantage uh the the game is uh on both
sides of the board so the bishop will do
very nicely here so if you move the
queen then black has a very natural
developing moves you can bring the rook
to b8 you can move the bishop bring the
other rook to c8 so here white trait we
have bishop captures and rook f to c1
now putting pressure on this pawn here
so black traits c captures knight
captures of course you do not want to
mess up your pawn structure and now rook
8 to b8 you're not worried about rook to
c7
as the b-21 is hanging so first b3 and
only now rook f the c8 and now we've
pretty much developed all of our pieces
and we asked black what do you want to
do here and it definitely makes sense
to get rid of all the rooks from the
board as like we already mentioned we
have the advantage of bishop against
tonight it's a it's a fairly open
position and the game is on both sides
of the board so
that's what we want to do we have knight
two to f3 white improves the position of
the knight maybe coming to e5 and now
king to f8 it's very important to uh
activate our king in the end game and
this is what dominguez paris is going
for also one thing we have to consider
here is that uh if everything disappears
off the board white has this two to one
advantage on the queen side white has
two points black has one so it's very
very easy for white to create a pass
pawn on the queen side and that could be
a problem if our king is stuck on h8 for
example we're not going to be able to
stop the past pawn so the white's only
plan here would be to trade off all the
pieces and start pushing pawns so we
have to activate our king we have
knights to e5 and now
king to e8 further activating the king
we have f4 and now knight to e4 so
an excellent square for the knight it
can't really be kicked away from there
we have a4 uh this knight also can be
kicked away from d4 it's on a dark
square black has a light square bishop
so it's gonna defend this pawn for uh
you know as long as we want but now
black says all right it's time to get
the rooks off the board rook captures
rook captures and simply rook the c8
we have rook capture sun c8 you could
also avoid this you could play rook to
b1 uh there are
uh maybe
uh you know uh positive sights the
the trading rooks but uh it it would be
considered i guess better not to trade
the rooks uh like we said the the bishop
should be stronger than a knight here
but okay we have rook captures bishop
captures it's uh materialistically it's
a completely even equal position and
like we said white has a two to one
advantage so white doesn't worry about
uh
such things we have b4 and now f6
getting rid of the knight from such a
wonderful square knight eat the c6 going
after the pawn and now a6 and now you
could go with b5 and create a pass pawn
right away but first knight to a7 we go
after the bishop here it's sort of a
little trick because if the king defends
we can simply pick it up and then win
the e6 pawn which is of course very good
for white so instead bishop to d7 and
now we're going to get our king into the
game and only now shankland
executes b5 and this will create a pass
pawn so a counters a captures now the uh
b b pawn is very strong of course we
have to do everything we can to stop it
uh king the d8 b6 um the king is locked
out of uh going after the pawn so maybe
not something
to do and the pawn is on the dark square
so we're not going to be able to
challenge it with a light square bishop
so here we have king the e7
now the bishop can move the king also
guards the e6 pawn and now b6
we have knight to c5
and knight eight to c6 with check asking
black do you want to give up your your
bishop for the knight and here it's
actually perfectly fine because this
spawn is now too far advanced it's not
going to be easy to defend it and now uh
dominguez perez just captures it we have
captures captures with czech king to d6
and now knight to d4 making sure uh that
you can't really reach the pawn as the
knight and
upon cover c6 and c7 but e5 will
dislodge this knight but first we have
to take care of our own pawn if we play
e5 right away knight f5 check picks up
the g7 pawn so first we have to tend to
that so g6 is played taking away the f5
square from the knight and now we have
king to f2 now shankland also starts
improving the position of the king uh
but see how uh you know when we started
discussing the same game white had a two
to one advantage on the queenside end he
had a bishop against tonight which was
kind of better as the game was on both
sides of the board but now the material
is completely equal both players have a
knight and uh perez has a much more
active king so here e5 chases away the
knight we have captures captures and now
knight to f3 still you can't really move
the king because the e5 pawn will fall
and e4 is a bit dangerous because the
the pawns are much stronger when they're
like this they control all of these
squares because now for example knight
g5 goes after the pawn h5 we're going to
play knight f7 check and now you still
can't go after the pawn if you go after
the pawn we can just play 95 check and
win this pawn for example so after
knight f3 we have knight to d7 the pawns
are better left like this now the knight
defends this pawn and we're gonna go
after this pawn with our king so knight
g5 goes after h5 h5 is played knight f7
check king the e7 now not going after
the pawn king e7 we kick away the knight
and then the knight will capture on b6
so knight g5 and now finally knight
captures on b6 so after all is said and
done black is now up upon and uh both
players still have a knight so can black
push this for a win well if so he has to
play very very precisely and the white
has to make a little
at least uh you know
a few mistakes here and there so here we
have e uh white plays e4 now tries to
eliminate as many pawns as possible or
if black pushes d4 then you're gonna
give the white king some squares to
maybe use uh to try and activate um uh
in in the position but here uh when
there are no pieces on the board we're
only playing a king and pawn in game you
want
eliminate as many pawns as possible
because uh well
your advantage will be greater and of
course we know that unless it's some
sort of a wicked position an extra pawn
will be winning however when there's a
knight on the board you do not want to
trade as many pawns as possible because
uh well let's say we trade all the pawns
you're left with one pawn your opponent
has zero pawns and your opponent just uh
gives up his knight for a pawn and it's
a draw by insufficient material so of
course we don't want to do that we we
played d4 and now king e2 now shanklin
will start improving the position of his
king uh knights to d7 so the pawn is
protected now the black king will also
be activating king to d3 first knight c5
check king c4 and now knight to e6 so
what do you do here uh well the problem
is of course trading knights
is not an option the king and pawn end
game is completely winning we have
knight back to f3 so putting pressure on
the e5 pawn and the king to d6 now uh
winning some squares for the black king
we have g3 and now uh of course we have
g5 that's how we make progress here we
have h4 and now the same principle
applies you have a a
a knight each on the board you do not
want to over trade
the pawn so just g4 let's keep the pawns
on the board we want to trade nights
here not pawns knights to d2 and now
knight to c5 putting pressure on this
pawn so the knight can't really move
king to b sorry not king to b4 king to
b5 and now knight to d3 so now we're
interested in going after this spawn
we're going to require a few moves like
knight f2 knight h1n8 captures on g3 but
white can always prevent this with a
simple knight to f1 and guards this
spawn so how can the black king make
progress here without the black king
being even more active you will not be
able to win this game so let's see how
perez does it we have king to c4 and now
knight to f2 we have king to b4 shanklin
is very happy just moving the king left
and right uh keeping the black king at
bay uh so king the d7 we have king to c4
and now knight to h1 going after the
pawn so knight to f1 only option here
and now comes king to c6 gaining the
opposition on the white king king to b4
now king to b6 and now king to c4
and here comes the the idea king the a5
now the problem is you can't really keep
the the black king uh
constantly locked out because uh the c3
square is controlled by black so you're
not going to be able to to use this
square for example if king b3 we can
play king b5 you don't have king c3 so
you're gonna have to let the the black
king in king c2 king c4 uh and so on
black king will continue making progress
so here we have king to d5 saying okay i
can grab this pawn this pawn will be
captured by the knight if it goes
anywhere
any further and maybe i can even reach
those pawns on the king's side but there
is a problem because now the position is
completely winning for black you have to
use both strategy and tactics to solve
this one feel free to pause the video
and win the game for dominguez perez
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting these two
pawns that they are too strong for the
knights to stop them on its own and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show of course it's knight captures on
g3 that's the good stuff
and the problem is of course if the
knight is captured just d3 you can't
stop both both of the pawns knight f1
we're going to play g3 now you either
capture this pawn or we're going to push
this pawn and then promote this pawn or
we just push this pawn so it doesn't
really matter the two pawns are
unstoppable knight captures d2 there's
no stopping this pawn from queening so
here shankland tried knight to d2 he
said all right i'm not going to capture
the pawn but now i'm down two points of
course this is now completely lost king
to b4
and now comes knight to c4
we have king to c3 and he was in this
position on move 55 that sam shanklin
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here everything is
nicely protected uh you can't really do
anything if you move the king you're
going to lose the knight
if the knight moves you don't really
care for example knight to a3 we're just
gonna move our own knight and then
promote this pawn to a queen so
absolutely everything is winning here
so yeah after king to c3 and move 55
shanklin resigned in the game and a
wonderful victory for uh linear
dominguez paris uh in this uh against
the london system so uh the london
system is uh you know uh spoken of uh
very often in in the chess world some
say it's a garbage some say it's a great
opening many people use it i often
mention how how magnus defeated vladimir
kramnik with the london system in the
world rapid championship or maybe it was
the world blitz championship can't
really remember
yeah i think it was blitz so uh you know
it's a strong opening but there are ways
to you know stop it or maybe even just
slow it down uh so there you have it if
you have problems with the london system
you are welcome to use this or you are
welcome to check out the the video that
i made how to counter the london system
might also come useful
if you if you enjoy such lines
so
that's the game i hope you guys enjoyed
it we're going to continue of course uh
with the coverage of the usgs
championship uh i would like to thank
olga the dinosaur david kimura ravindra
yoga be maltapa
miranda for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent start of your week